>>When you think about the diagnostic error or anchoring around a diagnosis,
having the patients read their note and actually see that
the physician clearly hear and understand the symptoms I was describing,
it has the opportunity to break a diagnostic anchoring.
>> One physician referred to me as having type 2 diabetes.
And someone had mentioned that a surgery that I
had was on the right side but it was on the left side.
So I've been able to go in and just let
the physicians know that you've made a mistake and they've corrected it.
>>It's not just patient engagement,
it's really about patient empowerment in care.
So we are basically inviting the patient,
we're nudging them and really asking them to go in and use this
and not just read it in a sort of passive way but give
us feedback on it and tell us what we could do,
what we did wrong, and tell us what we could do to make it better.
That's huge. We have not done very much of that in medicine.
We've just told the patient what to do.
>>I think one of the benefits for everybody moving away from
doctor knows best to doctor and
patient working together is that it's going to be recognized.
So the team owns the outcome.
>>I guess I am somebody who believes that trust will
be easier to come by between doctor and patient if there's more candor and openness.
Doctors and patients and family members who know that
there's a level of transparency will shift their behavior.
>>The thing that I care about the most with our department is what we call culture,
and culture is built in small acts.
Every little small thing you do that makes the environment more respectful,
more inclusive of patients creates that culture.
This is probably not a small, thing this is a big thing.
But for me, that's what this is,
this is another aspect of a way to be respectful,
inclusive and partner in patients for the ultimate goal
of improving their care and their satisfaction with our care.
So that's why I love openness.